[Music]
missy's story is a story of a woman's
courage
[Music]
it's about a woman who
is trying to find herself again
after the loss of her husband
[Music]
it's a relatable story of family and
marriage
and then it goes to a place that only a
wild imagination
like stephen king could could take you
[Music]
it's a very scary story in a lot of ways
it's scary in a supernatural way but
it's also scary because
there really are dangerous people out
there
this is a story about love and
relationships and how we
save each other
[Music]
it's so multi-layered you know it's
terribly romantic
it's terrifying at times and it's
upsetting and it's full of pain
and beauty lisey is completely grief
stricken
i've left lisia bullhun i've given her
clues that she
is diving into with her grief
nobody really knows what goes on in a
marriage except the two people who are
in it
what is that world that only the two of
them know about
lisey is kind of drawn into this world
lisie is trying to save her sister and
save her husband
and then there's this kind of outside
pressure where someone is menacing her
all the time when scott dies
my character wants his unpublished works
to be published he thinks
lisi is holding them away from the
public
so he makes it his mission he'll do
pretty much anything
to make sure that happens secret secrets
are no fun secret secrets hurt someone
we are straddling whole different worlds
and in some ways whole different genres
i think that in and of itself is really
unusual
to have this kind of this horror the
supernatural element
come back
it's very unique and unusual
a really strong beautiful vision
it just works on so many levels
[Music]
stephen king has cracked this beautiful
story he's someone who's been able to
understand our humanity in a very
universal way
this is a love story
it's a beautiful unearthly thing
you